Compris
Guard est apparu le 22 septembre en tant que
une fois quand la mobilisation a été annoncée et nous
pensé que dans ce cas, sinon laisser
Dieu attaquera ou certains
danger pour les personnes pour les citoyens ordinaires
et les enfants pour les personnes âgées Vous devez apprendre
protégez vous et vos proches
solution
très intéressant sur le plan
plongez dans tout cela voici le développement
c'est-à-dire, c'est du patriotisme en premier lieu
tour vous commencez à comprendre notre
enfants de nos maris pères grands-pères c'est-à-dire
comment tout ce qu'ils ont fait à travers ce qu'ils
ont eu lieu même pendant les services d'urgence
ça donne vraiment beaucoup
moi je pense
me critique pour l'apparence que nous sommes
La garde des femmes est coquine
cheveux avec des ongles avec des anneaux
ongles peints je le répète
tout ce qu'il peut même être à nous
trait distinctif est que nous avons toujours même
tout en tenant la machine entre nos mains
Je tiens un lance-grenades et je tire un mortier
je serai toujours une femme je serai toujours
belle je vais battre les boucles dans la plupart des cas
situations d'auto-soins
[musique]